what if i told you
there is a system right now that can
take natural language input so whatever
description you want just make something
up and it will take that text
and turn it into a surprisingly
realistic image
of exactly what you described so you
type an astronaut riding a horse and it
spits out a brand new image of an
astronaut riding a horse you type teddy
bears shopping for groceries and boom
there's an image of teddy bear shopping
for groceries you type a bowl of soup
that is a portal to another dimension
and boom my god it's a bowl of soup
that's a portal to another dimension and
it's not just one it actually spits out
10 different versions across a spectrum
of variation in any art style you want
you name it and it can draw it so what
is happening here how does it work
and
what happens if i try
so first things first yes this does
exist this is a real thing it's called
dolly 2 and it's an ai research project
by a company called openai one of many
elon musk co-founded companies at this
point and so the purpose of this ai
specifically is to create original
realistic images and art
from a text description this is aditya
ramesh a researcher and co-creator of
dolly one and dolly two he's easily the
most qualified person to explain what's
happening here um so the way w1
generates images dolly one generates an
image
starting from the top left and moving
industrial order row viral so diffusion
works completely differently the way
diffusion works is we train a model to
reverse a corruption process that's
applied to clean images so it's kind of
hard to wrap your head around but
basically there's two main ai
technologies behind dolly two they're
called clip
and diffusion so clip is the part that's
matching images to text and basically
uses that match to train the computer to
understand concepts in images so it can
generate new images of the same concepts
so when i asked it for an astronaut
riding a horse for example it's not just
making a mosaic of images it found
online it knows the idea of what an
astronaut is it knows what the concept
of writing means it knows what a horse
is and maybe most impressively it knows
what's an aesthetically pleasing image
to humans so then it can create a
completely new visual version of this
idea that hasn't existed before now clip
doesn't really have the ability to do
the pretty high resolution images all by
itself it's just more generating the
gist of an image based on those concepts
so that is where diffusion comes in so
diffusion is super impressive basically
by teaching a computer to corrupt an
image by adding gaussian noise it can
then learn to
uncorrupt or enhance an image by
removing that noise
it's kind of like step one draw the
circle step two draw the rest of the owl
so i don't know if you've ever seen this
website called this person does not
exist.com but if you haven't you should
check it out it shows you a surprisingly
realistic image of a face
but as you might have guessed this
person does not exist it's not a real
face it's actually using ai to look at
thousands of faces and then generate a
new face with that information that is
shockingly realistic but it turns out is
not a real human so dolly dolly 2 is
like a way more advanced
generalized version of that
for anything so when you open it up it's
literally just a blank search text box
where you can type in whatever you want
to create now of course as you can
probably imagine with all these concerns
and possibilities this isn't just a tool
that's available to the public it's not
like anyone can use it openai has kept
this mostly behind closed doors to a
very small hand-selected group of people
but for a day
they gave me the keys
and i was able to generate
whatever i want
which of course means i had to ask it to
finally reveal to us what the
long-awaited apple car would look like i
mean this is an opportunity unlike any
other so i typed it in i waited my 10
seconds with great breath and then the
secret was finally unveiled
oh
right
of course i don't know why i expected
anything different but for real okay so
the open ai team was kind enough to
allow me to feed dolly 2 whatever i want
so i decided to start pretty simple and
then get a little bit more complex as we
go so a blue apple
and a bowl of oranges
so okay
these are good these are actually
i mean that was extremely easy
but the sharpness
the realism the lighting even
to just create these brand new out of
nothing there is so much detail in this
one it's kind of hard to believe it
isn't real okay an elderly
kangaroo
i mean
i don't know what i expected
specifically an elderly kangaroo to look
like i guess maybe i
pictured
gray hair or something but
i buy it i mean the fact that it's again
it's not a real photo but it looks like
a real photo of an elderly kangaroo that
is very impressive a wise elephant
staring at the moon at night
whoa okay so that is definitely a wise
elephant he or she is in fact staring at
the moon and it is definitely at night
it's not bad
the moon does look a little bit wonky if
you if you look a little bit closer on
some of these it's not perfect but the
elephant is very real looking okay let's
get a little more specific here a teddy
bear doing surgery on a grape
in the style of a 1990s cartoon
oh my god look at these cartoons
sometimes it misses totally
understandable also it seems to have
chosen scissors instead of maybe a more
realistic actual surgery i'll get to why
in a minute but the facial expressions
the feet and everything i mean
that is a teddy bear doing surgery on a
grape all right this one's from mac the
studio dog
a cooker hunch i'm pronouncing that
wrong
using a camera on a movie set
wow
that is okay if you couldn't already
tell that is the name of the dog breed
and
the closer you inspect each individual
image
the more the photo realism part kind of
falls apart which maybe isn't shocking
because this is kind of a crazy thing to
have a picture of but the detail in the
dog breed and it actually
using the camera in the pictures
is crazy good i wonder if we could post
that to mac's instagram if anybody would
notice that it's not a real picture i'd
probably figure it out all right a robot
woman
guarding a wall of computers
wow okay so
so many interesting details and
decisions being made in these images so
the word guarding implies a bit of a
pose and there's a couple different
guarding poses here but that's cool the
computers for the most part are also
pretty convincing if you don't zoom in
too much
and also it's interesting that none of
the walls of computers go all the way up
to the ceiling either which is cool but
that is definitely a robot woman
guarding that wall of computers alright
what if we go
a tiger discovering the lost city of
atlantis
wow okay these are more of an art style
probably because
one
there won't be any like photo realistic
reference images of the lost city of
atlantis so i imagine it'll look better
this way
and two
this is a crazy image to create so with
each of these they're great without
zooming in and pixel peeping and they
very much accomplish the goal of
illustrating a tiger discovering
atlantis like i asked the crazy part
here though to me is how much
imagination
it's using like i'm actually getting
more than what i asked for the facial
expressions poses
orientation of things reflections even
the accurate lighting in shadows is
crazy like i asked for a tiger
discovering atlantis here but it's
decided to add trees and birds and a
moon all by itself all right here we go
here we go a painting inspired by the
mona lisa
of a goat taking pictures with an ipad
i
this is my new favorite thing
you you can really just go off the rails
with complexity and it just gets them
right
almost all of these goats have hands too
which is hilarious but the drawings
themselves have actually also stayed
true to the theme it's a painting in the
style of the mona lisa and the tablets
are all
you know varying levels of convincing
ipads wow i'm going to put these all on
twitter by the way in like one big
thread plus a few extras if they don't
make it into the video so definitely hit
the link below if you want to see those
but last but not least a cyclops riding
a tractor listening to airpods in the
style of the simpsons
i mean
come on
maybe it's not a perfect cyclops and it
is
interesting that it's chosen over the
ear headphones for all of the headphones
and not you know airpod earbuds but
i feel like there's nothing this can't
do this is one of those ai tools that's
so good that it almost brings up more
questions than it answers like why does
a tool like this even exist in the first
place well dolly 2 is a research project
not a customer product and open ai's
goal is to create
good
safe
general ai which is really hard like
there are a lot of really really good
task specific ai systems that'll do
things from like detecting cancer in
x-rays to self-driving cars that
navigate the streets or just sharpening
photos in photoshop but the whole
general ai thing which needs a ton of
information to be able to navigate a ton
of different situations is a whole other
challenge i mean if you think like
tesla robot walking around the earth
completing tasks for you like that's the
level we're talking about here and so
being able to recognize objects and
images and associate them very quickly
and accurately is a big part of that now
are there things that dolly doesn't do
well yes actually there are both some
intentional and some unintentional
shortcomings of dolly 2 as it exists
right now so on the intended side uh the
library of images that dolly references
is massive but it doesn't have any
images of adult content or illegal
activity or violence so it doesn't
create images with that stuff in it
makes sense that's probably why we got
scissors in the teddy bear's hand
instead of a knife because that's the
next closest association the ai was able
to make for that surgery and you also
can't ask for imagery of specific
identities of people so you can ask for
man robbing a bank but you can't ask for
marquez brownlee robbing a bank
as curious as i am about what type of
image that would spit out you can't that
would be dangerous for obvious reasons
but also dolly 2 is known to have some
quirks so one of them is it doesn't do
very well specifically with variable
binding or what basically will happen
when you ask for relative position of
objects in an image so if i ask for a
red cube on top of a blue cube it might
just give you a blue cube on top of a
red cube and we actually saw this in one
of the images i got back for a blue
apple and a bowl of oranges well right
there that's clearly an orange in a bowl
of blue apples which is kind of funny
and it also for whatever reason doesn't
do written text well so sometimes it can
give you certain letters but if you ask
it for like a sign that says a certain
word it'll almost never actually give
you that there's actually a pretty
hilarious twitter thread of someone
asking dolly for signs with certain
things over and over again just to see
what random text it spits out which is
also pretty funny but this is the type
of stuff that i'll be working on for
dolly 3 and for future versions as you
can imagine but it's funny with every
shortcoming they found there was also an
equally awesome accidental upside they
discovered too like this diffusion
method can also
transform images so you can take an
existing image and run the model over
and over to push it more and more
towards any prompt you want so you can
take this plain jacket for example and
slowly turn it into a jackson pollock
painting or take this picture of a cat
and slowly turn it into a samurai master
or take a picture of tech a piece of
tech and slowly un-modernize it over and
over like look what it does to this
iphone it turns it back into an older
and older phone
it's modifying existing images based on
other existing concepts it's it's kind
of sick so is this going to be taking
people's jobs well lucky for you if you
want the exact answer to that question
that's literally the concept we attacked
with the new studio video so i'll link
it below the like button if you want to
watch it but we pit dolly 2 up against
tim who is the graphic designer here at
the mkbhd studio where their jobs are
kind of basically the same thing it's to
turn the words coming out of my mouth
into a good-looking image
spoiler alert if you give tim enough
time he'll make something better but in
10 seconds dolly is able to spit out a
bunch of different variations and while
the images might be a bit fuzzy around
the edges or have weird text or fall
apart when you zoom in on faces or hands
or objects
this tool as presently constructed
is amazing for brainstorming ideas and
concepts and things that would normally
take much longer to create is truly an
amazing side effect of the development
of this ai that it's able to make this
tool where the images that it spits out
aren't necessarily supposed to be
finished final pieces of work
but they are a great starting point for
making stuff later that's actually
exactly what we did with this video's
thumbnail which started off as an image
generated by dolly where it was told to
make a robot hand drawing so i have no
doubt that there will be versions of
dolly in the future that make even
higher resolution and more
photorealistic images
and then
even better like quick animations
and then video clips and then whole
movies even all on our way
to this general ai goal that we're
working towards
what a time to be alive
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace